how's it going rest my name welcome back
to mad father my father has gone crazy
I found this code in the memo which has
low like my face that's like a clue so I
need to find barrels in the forest floor
east hole on second floor is tall I
think it's down here dammit dammit don't
you dare [ __ ] with me first right it's
all one two three four five six seven
nail that bench what's next
chandeliers in the entrance hole it's
gotta be here right one two three four
watch it fall away okay we're safe we're
fine seven four red dolls in the doll
room
I think the doll room it is something
solve it over here oh [ __ ] it's the
piano guy he's really good at
moonwalking while let moon laying I
guess it's called here we go seven four
one two three four six
yes progress [ __ ] progress
paintings and reception room well where
the [ __ ] is the reception room don't
[ __ ] with me zombies don't [ __ ] with me
damn it there we go nail that [ __ ]
deception room in hello Crowley let me
just save on you um two seven four seven
seven six four [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's that
I thought I heard someone in her [ __ ]
hello
bathroom let's check it out oh it's full
of blood job love huh oh [ __ ] I don't
even know what it put seven four six two
I'm saving on you you little [ __ ] I
don't even know where to put that it's a
code memo where's the code
[ __ ] jump scares man I don't even
understand what the [ __ ] what are you I
Joel oh [ __ ] that's it nasty I shake it
yo I shake it yo check for me girl shake
funny girl huh
check for Maga shake for meager give me
that gam cafeteria key Oh hon what are
you going [ __ ] I hate jump scares what's
so funny huh what's that darling moaning
it's part of the curse - well we don't
need to go here
Rocky's a mess
[ __ ] yeah I don't need you to be happy
all right we got the cafeteria key I
don't even know what that is
let me save on your crow a crowd shave
crow I'm not sure you crow
I've been told that I can pick up
snowballs so I guess I got to do it yes
your comic was made snowy snow here
snowball snowball loves father too don't
you
what is this cutscene snowball snowball
where are you what do I do and your legs
had to I'm worried
snowball took the words out of my mouth
where did you get to I was so worried
when you dissipate
I couldn't wrap up that wound with you
running around wait huh
you once healed yeah what a troublesome
rabbir Oh
father I uh try not to let snowball out
of your sight well you the rabid made a
mess out of the kitchen he pooed
everywhere sorry
someone must have been trying to get a
bite of Maria's cookie again huh
Oh her cookie all right did you find
snowball father yes and here that leg
wound while I was at it so good at
reading good thing fathers around a
snowball
thank you Father snowballs a member of
the family treated as well as any other
yeah
I'm sure that's how she said it yeah
yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry sorry about
that all right what do we get let's go
save father together so well if you get
in my way
don't you dare [ __ ] things up for me all
right we need to go to the reception key
or whatever plus we have a spaz I gotta
I'm gonna guess it's this door here
yes it was called cafeteria though it's
a share why did I do yeah they made you
sound like someone is choking on yeah oh
okay
what the [ __ ] don't eat me don't you can
have snowball it snowballs but not me I
should stay away why is his carpet left
dead but I do I click the carpet secret
found like a boss here
I can't go down there alright so I need
to like it
I need like a I got oil alright that's
good fine
whoa jab blood [ __ ] crazy dogs man
all right we need a we need shut up
Davis need a lamb West Passage is like
what about this one Oh a gem
I said it right there's something there
a pendant hello crow a crow I like you
all right is this where you put the code
or where to suppose you put the code
scattered bags
humans are beautiful but their beauty
soon fades that is a lot of world
but I overturn it after years of
research I found internal DNA a body
that will never fade even in death a
body as fresh as when they were still
alive they have eternal beauty within
their grasp sounds wonderful
flame eggs what I remember this book
there's a girl who has mystery power to
control fire and she goes on a journey
to find the family she's been separated
from it sounds like me right now
proclaiming burn all those in my way she
did exactly that taller foes but I think
in the end her power got out of control
and destroy the world that's nice so she
never met her family in the end she was
all alone
a poor girl all allowed if I his father
I would be alone too I don't want it
wants to be alone I have to say father
quick we don't even know if he's in
danger and I honestly so don't counsel
oh how about you use like thing that we
figure it out together
all right archives is [ __ ] that means
what about here
arms dresser safe Paulo needs a code oh
yeah we have the code
all right so 708 I was Jesus Christ
7 4 6 - all right let's find us what the
code is so Emma what is this whoa
Oh Shh is anything get it up whoa job
blood what if it's pushing like I'm
pushing that like crazy what do you want
from bag get off me you disgusting [ __ ]
oh it's only one there's only one
painting now jesus [ __ ] christ man
man that was crazy but here's my number
why do I do that I'm sorry 7 4 4 6 1 ma
vie 6ic fry sounded what excuse me
princess eyebrows out of sheer genius
nests and absolutely no cheating I
figured out this code now big al you son
of a [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate you it
contains mom belonging sorry mama you
mean that about you it smells like mom
she parks ha ha ha ha there's a lamp in
that finally it might be useful just
borrowing this mom your mom is gone
well it's again this is monster 10 and
it would explain why smells like your
mama
and now the lovely cutsie is he still at
work we're you marry a doctor yeah
father hiya there you are
doesn't your father always tell you not
to go in the basement mom bit man hey I
knew it he's cheating on me with her I
can't believe this
some girl II picked up on this street I
won't forgive him
well that's kind of [ __ ] in front she
just leaves her daughter there that's
the nice okay do the parenting she
kissed the mirror ah there's a stupid
thing it what what is that
mom usually so nice but she seems so
different then this perfume I'll put it
back in a dresser after that but she
took care of it that's good
after all mom got this from father on
their anniversary so I'm sure mom loved
farther to the very end
oh I'll take these as champs all right
mom got moms with yup close the vault
looking at mom's dresser now we can save
that's trichroic Rao save growl gotta
learn much are you alright somebody to
go where exactly we need to go away ah
here here here I got this kid's got this
know what happened to the lamp whatever
did it laughs whatever let's try and go
down anyway you still AM
oh the lamb Jana's parent strikes again
sore huh Oh shet barrels [ __ ] hell
man hole in the wall go snowball go push
snowball go snowball go go snowball go
I'm playing a snowball this is the best
game ever
huh why did I go back in snowball Khan's
is safe today that means I'm not gay I'm
snowball [ __ ] I'm not a
snowball hey just gonna hate a lighter
oil said it sound like someone is typing
seriously I don't like this I don't not
like this
snowball what are you doing huh snowball
your honor
uh-oh I suspect please oh wow that is
creepy man just imagining it whoa
damn that's for snowball how let me make
sense what is that welcome back in place
at least didn't need snowball I have
lighter oil ow I don't really know what
to do with job [ __ ] shut Marta here I'm
outta here I'm not you again
how did I miss that it was eight dolls
in this room eight red ones oh there
they are
okay figured as much
shut up whoa dine vade that amount of
data that's nice that's really nice
thank you
what a compliment maybe these obey back
and kill I should burn this away I get
it
I can't get through here what should I
do I know I like the flame egg burn oh I
could burn those [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah burn them burn them I'll
use the lighter oil I know one thing I
haven't tried out yet and it's I think
it's in this room shut up shut your
mouth oh let me go inside woman let me
go inside we're gonna push you and we're
gonna push you here
maybe now no and maybe now just cutting
knife I know exactly what I'm gonna use
you on this [ __ ] box I swear
Ellen [ __ ] I'm serious this time around
I didn't I didn't actually shake I cut
that [ __ ] now we have an empty lighter
[ __ ] yeah fill that [ __ ] Jess progress
[ __ ]
Jesus Christ I thought lighters were
filled with with it's not really oily is
it yeah it is oh well I'm stupid
never mind I find someone likes your
funnel we're gonna burn that abomination
in German - fire - fire
yep just do it yes just do it yes die
[ __ ] burn [ __ ] dead
birds and birds help me oh whoops
was that may Gus dine all right let me
pass
Jesus bunch of wimps hello crow a crow
oh we're gonna go in the laboratory now
brass but in the next episode it's like
a bird if you enjoy subscribe comradely
and I'll see you in next episode oh wow
I'm a Salesman right I'm the second vice
Lady Gaga Lady gotta go and wax we have
to sacrifice him stirs sorry I'm sorry